The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today was a
little different than yesterday.
So I thought it
would be good for us
to just sort of
recap what happened.
Let's go back to the
sixth graders visit.
Thank you, Jamie, for
prepping them for it.
I woke up this morning.
I was like, I didn't
prep them for it.
If I were them, I would
have been super overwhelmed.
I'm a terrible person.
Was that helpful to you?
What did you guys think
about that whole experience?
AUDIENCE: I immediately knew
that whatever ideas I had
yesterday was completely off.
And wrong.
180 degrees in the
wrong direction.
PROFESSOR: I mean,
do take what they
say with a grain of
salt. Sixth graders
don't always know how to
articulate what they want.
In a pitch, robots always sound
cooler than food decomposing.
But there is a way
to make that awesome,
if that's really what
you're interested in.
So as with everything
in this class,
the feedback is
ultimately for you
to decide what to do with it.
Was there anything
surprising that
came out of the first hour?
I know it's hard to put yourself
back into that perspective.
That's what I meant yesterday
with the whole thoughtfulness
quality.
One of the values
of the class is
being able to take yourself
out of the perspective
that you have here.
We were shooting science out
loud during the first season
with two grad students
who are in AeroAstro.
They were making a video
about how engines work.
And we were discussing
one of the scenes
that they had planned was to
describe a turbine engine.
And I'll go into this more
during Thursday's lecture.
But one of the
students was trying
to describe that it's
the turbine blades that
push the air forward.
And we he was thinking to
do an animation with it.
And we thought, this
is really complicated.
I couldn't understand
what he was trying to say.
And finally, the other
student who was there
was like, oh, well there's
one Boeing 777 in the hangar
in that building over there.
Like, is it worth
filming with it?
And just sort of that
mentality of like,
you have access to an
actual turbine engine.
And it didn't cross
your mind to film it.
And they were
awesome to work with.
And you know, that the
whole day of shooting
was actually really fun.
But the ability to take
yourself out of the things
that your experience all the
time, or take for granted.
Creating that window for
people who don't necessarily
have access to the
world that you live in
is surprisingly difficult to do.
And hopefully the
first hour of classes
sort of helped you orient
into that new perspective.
But I know that's a challenge
for me a lot of times
is, I don't think people
are going to think
this is super interesting.
And it's not the content that's
not interesting to people.
It's just the delivery.
How you package it up.
PROFESSOR: I think that getting
the right angle for-- like,
some of you had
really broad topics.
Right?
And the thing that's
really hard is
that there are so many
things within that topic that
could be really interesting.
And like the food
decomposing thing.
Actually think there are
a billion really cool
topics in there that
could be really fun.
Like cheese is technically mold.
And why is some mold
good, and some mold bad.
Right?
And there's some
really cool things
like that can do about that.
And getting back to microbiome
things, or bacteria,
or there's some really
cool stuff in there.
And just like every
one of your topics
that you guys brought up.
There's some really
cool little pieces
of truths inside of there.
And the hard part
is figuring out
how to give-- I mean,
this is what writers do,
is having the right
angle to your story.
Right?
And so, many-- I think
all of what I heard,
I heard many your ideas.
I'm like we're in
the right zip code,
but we haven't quite narrowed
down the right building yet.
Right?
Or the right street.
And for the hard
part is figuring out
within the topic
of shipbuilding,
or within the idea of hacking,
or building a game, what
is that little cool
angle that you're are
going to take to make it really
exciting and interesting?
And snare enough and focused
enough and that kind of thing
that makes it
really interesting.
Because I do think actually
that lava sounds cooler
to like a sixth grader
because they're like, lava!
That's cook.
Right?
But the food one.
I'm not ready to
give up on that yet.
Like, I think there's a
lot of cool stuff in there.
And the hard part is
figuring out, really
narrowing down your story.
And then figuring out which
one has more meat to it.
PROFESSOR: I mean, I think
it's a very beautiful story,
actually.
The whole idea of material
objects on this earth
transforming in a way
that's tangible to us.
And maybe that's just like
super romantic sounding.
But I do think that there is-- I
loved what Chris said yesterday
about making not just
the unfamiliar familiar,
but making the
familiar unfamiliar.
And I think that's a lot of
what of what VSauce does.
And I think that's a
lot of what Veritasium
does is it's taking the
things that you see,
and taking the world that you're
used to seeing, and showing you
a new lens at looking at it.
And I know that
sounds very abstract.
And I'm sure that we've
thrown out a lot of things
to think about that you're
not maybe quite sure
how to implement on
a practical level.
And I promise that that's
what we're going to hit next.
And once you guys
write a script tonight,
or just try writing
it, it'll help
you a lot to sort
of understand how
to implement these things
practically speaking.
So worry.
I am aware that that might be
a frustration that you have.
PROFESSOR: I wonder if we have
a little time today to give them
more time to flesh out
their ideas a little more.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
So I was originally
planning on showing you guys
a couple hosting case studies.
But if you would find
it more helpful to just
maybe brainstorm script ideas--
PROFESSOR: I feel like that's
where they are right now.
If you think I'm wrong.
But I feel like today made
you think a little more.
And now before you go home
and have to really implement
some idea, maybe it's worth
really making sure each of you
know what you want to do before.
I don't know.
What do you guys think?
I'm feeling some
anxiety right now
that like it would
help to flesh out
your ideas out a little more.
Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
We will totally do that.
I did want to show
you something.
Because for me personally,
it's hard for me
to hear abstract level ideas.
And I just need
to see an example
to help understand that.
So.
And again, I'm not saying
that the way I necessarily
do things or the way George
or any of the teaching staff
do things is necessarily
the best way.
Because again, best is
not really been defined.
But this was a video we
did during second season.
And it was the first
biology video that any of us
had worked on, which I
was really excited about.
But it did present
these challenges
of like how do you create a
visually interesting video
that's worth making as a video.
Because again, I mean,
I think asking yourself,
like why do I need
to make an animation
about synthetic biology
when I could just
create a cartoon about it?
As Chris was saying,
visual elements, just
pictorial representations of
things are very, very engaging.
We really were asking
ourselves, like what's
going to be the visual
purpose of her explaining
what basically became a little
bit about systems biology,
actually.
And one of the things
that we really fixated on,
which is an idea of
hers, was a metaphor.
And so this is about a
four minute long episode.
Would you guys
mind if showed it?
And then we can
workshops scripts.
But let me turn off this.
Is the light already off?
You guys can see it OK, right?
OK.
So I'll show this to
you guys and maybe we
can un-pack what you've think
is successful or not successful
about our attempt.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Paclitaxel is a
compound that can
treat cancer-- Paclitaxel is a
compound that can treat cancer.
salicylic acid reduces
headaches and fevers.
Carotenoids can turn
your skin orange.
And miraculin changes
your sense of taste.
What do all of these awesome
compounds have in common?
They all come from plants!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
More than 100,000 natural
compounds occur in plants
and we barely explore them.
These small molecules
are called metabolites.
Just like how all the DNA in
an organism forms the genome,
all of the metabolites
form the metabolome.
Even though it's metabolite can
be made from only six elements,
there are so many
possibilities that it
would take scientists thousands
of years to make each one try
and figure out its usefulness.
Luckily, plants have
already done this for us.
Plants have the disadvantage
of being rooted to the ground.
So over time they've
trial and errored
making lots of compounds
to see which ones help
them survive and thrive best.
And because they've
been interacting
with other species like us for
100s of thousands of years,
some of their chemicals turn
out to be really useful,
both inside and
outside our bodies.
But to use plants to
their full potential,
we have to know what chemicals
they make and how to make them.
Instead of studying
every chemical one
by one, what if we could
study all of them at once?
We could start by mapping
the huge network that
connects metabolites.
In any living
organism, molecules
are always on the move.
Being converted and shuttled,
decomposed and built
back up again and re-used.
It's just like a subway system!
Except in biology, the
people are the chemicals
and the train is the enzyme
that converts and moves them.
If you look at a
city from above,
how could you map the
whole subway system?
Similarly, if we
look at a plant,
how could you figure out the
entire metabolome network?
To figure out a
path and a system,
what we actually need
to do is break it.
If we mutate or
disrupt a pathway
and see how the metabolite
quantities change,
we could figure out the
connections between them.
Let's say the train from
Central to MIT breaks.
We wouldn't see students
arriving at MIT,
and would instead see them
building up at Central.
But not only that.
Anyone else traveling
along the red line
would also be affected.
So it's the
redistribution of people
which reveals the
red line subway path,
and tells us where
the train broke.
We can use the systems thinking
to uncover the plant metabolite
network.
For example, we know about
a compound sinapoyl malate
which protects the
plant from UV damage
by interacting with UV light,
making the plant grow green.
But without it, the
plant would glow red.
So if we see a red plant,
it's like seeing no people
at the sinapoyl malate station.
But we wouldn't yet know
where the train broke,
or what other stations
are along the route.
To do that, we can
mutate a lot of seeds,
plant them, and
choose the reds ones.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now we can analyze these samples
by using the mass spectrometer.
It measures how much
of each metabolite
is present in the sample.
Then we can use a program to see
which compounds were effected
and map that part
of the network.
It's like reviewing
the red line.
Once we figure out how the
entire metabolome works,
we can use it to engineer plants
to create new bio materials,
medicines, and clean energy.
We might even discover
that plants have
the secret to living forever.
We just need to unlock
their chemical mysteries.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So Anastasia's
topic was-- it
was really hard to visualize.
It mean, if you can
imagine, our first meeting
she was talking about basically
mapping chemical pathways
in plants.
And it's a hard concept
to describe verbally.
And I think that there are
some things that we did well
with that video.
I still feel like
sometimes it's easy to get
lost in the metaphor that it
doesn't really do as precise
of a job as it could.
One of the things I did want to
hit though because someone had
asked, how do you
know if your idea
is too-- was it
you who asked, how
do you know your idea
is too big, or not?
You're not going to
appeal to everyone.
And you're not going to be the
perfect video for every viewer.
And that's OK.
I think understanding your niche
is one of the biggest lessons
that I learned in
producing Science Out Loud.
At the beginning, our
intention and our goal
was to be something
like SciShow or VSauce.
Something that kids just
sort of watch on their own.
And we quickly realized that
that won't necessarily be
the case for us and that's OK.
And that we serve a very
powerful function being coupled
in classrooms, or after
school programs, or parents
watching them with their kids.
And that'll dictate what
concessions you might make.
I mean, in this
video, we kind of just
said whoever is
going to watch it
is going to understand a
little bit about chemistry
and biology.
And that is what allowed
us to sort of gloss over
some of the details
about chemical pathways.
I think that video
worked for us, that there
was a reason that we
made that video partially
because Anastasia I think
is really good on screen.
And that if you didn't
have her, and if you
had just a narrated
video or an animation,
it would be a very
different visual experience.
I don't know if you guys
agree with that or not.
But that's sort of how I felt.
The other thing is, she
naturally as a person is really
like that.
She's really jazzed
about biology.
It's OK if your personality
is not like that.
But the way she wrote
her script-- I mean,
she was probably one of the
best during the day of shoot
just remembering her lines.
Because the way she
wrote her script
was the way that she
just sort of talks
about that stuff in real life.
And that was a big tip that
I wanted to give you guys
before you started scripting,
was right things the way
that you would say it.
And George will talk about
this a lot tomorrow, as well.
It's a very, very
obvious statement
that is very, very
difficult to implement.
I don't know if you guys were
pay attention to that in some
of the BioBuilder videos.
their purpose is to
be very instructional
like Natalie was saying.
It's like a very
encyclopedic type of product.
And it works well in
schools, but most people
don't talk in their
everyday conversation
like those characters did.
And that's OK for their product.
But if your intent is to engage
someone like Hank Green does,
then you have to
think about the way
that you're writing your script.
And again that may sound
like a very abstract tip.
So what I would
say is, if you're
struggling with
that in your script,
literally read your words aloud.
And then put your script away
so that you can't see it.
And just explain
your sentence sort
of ad libbed to
someone next to you.
So this happens a lot to me.
I actually went through
all the exercises
that you guys are going
to do this month myself
to sort of see if what
I was saying made sense.
And George and I created
an episode about snot.
And the writing process for
me was a lot harder for me
than I thought it would be,
even though I've coached
so many people through it.
And it was because I
fell into this habit
of being super newscastery.
And that's my personal habit
that-- I'll say things like,
you think this would do this.
But turns out, it doesn't.
Right?
And I would say,
this sounds awful.
And George would
take my script away
and he would say, Elizabeth,
what is so cool about snot?
And I'd say, well it's
awesome because you
think that it's just
like this crap that
flows out of your body.
But it turns out that has like
all these really amazing things
about it.
And he would say, well
you should just say that.
So as you script, or as
you try to think of ideas,
turn to your partner.
And just tell them as you
would tell anyone what it is
you're trying to convey, what
it is you're excited about.
Do you need to do-- want
to add anything to that?
PROFESSOR: Well,
I think right now
we've got about 35 minutes
before the end of class.
And I suspect we
have some wrap up
that we need to do to talk
about what to do tonight
and what to do to get
ready for tomorrow.
So that really puts us
more at 20, 25 minutes.
Right?
I feel like maybe
what we need to do
is old school actually
have each of one of you
think with paper and pen
and brainstorm a little.
And then come back together
as a group a little bit,
so that you have some time
to really conceptualized.
Like if I were to
do this on my own,
I'm just saying like, I would
actually do an old school
spiderweb to get my ideas out.
Which is-- put
this guy down here.
I would actually probably
put my topic in the middle
and start brainstorming
everything
that I can about it to just keep
me thinking about what, like--
and then to maybe realize if
shipbuilding is in the middle
here and we talked about
ships, like what specifically
within ships am
I thinking about?
Did we want to talk
about sea sickness?
All right, then if I wanted
to talk sea sickness,
what would I put in my video?
Right?
And to really
visualize for yourself,
all the topics, concept,
things you would want to film.
And then start getting
a sense for yourself
of whether or not this
is a doable concept.
And you may realize
that actually this
is the branch I want
to keep exploring,
as opposed to this
whole big thing.
And if this were my brain,
that's how this would work.
But if there's a different
way that your brain works,
we want you-- I would
think that you should use
this time a little bit solo.
And then we'll have a chance
to maybe bounce some ideas off.
So I feel like
people, at least what
I heard from people was
that this morning was
really helpful.
But it made you
realize you really
need to narrow your
topic and really
think it through a little bit.
So maybe what we do is we
spend about 10 minutes quietly
working on our own to really
flesh out our concepts.
And then we get back
together as a group.
Do you need paper.
I have paper.
Does anyone need-- you
need some paper and pen?
I'll go grab them in my office.
I'll go get some.
PROFESSOR: Real quick.
I mean, there are
so many strategies.
And some people have
different preferences
of beginning to script.
I wasn't going to share
this until tonight.
But maybe it would help
to do it right now.
So when I was sitting
down to script
the snot episode--
and again, I'm
not saying that this is
the best way to do it.
Nor am I saying it's
the right way to do it.
But I was fixated on
the idea that your body
makes a gallon of snot a day.
That was really the seed that
began the idea of the episode.
So George, who
you'll meet tomorrow,
said, well just list
every amazing thing
about snot that you
want to talk about.
So I didn't even start with an
idea of a story or anything.
All I did was list
every sort of fact
about mucus that I
was interested in.
And this is sort of the same
concept of having a web.
I just put in a list.
But it doesn't really matter.
And as I was going
through-- and some of this
was stuff that I had learned in
a class I took as an undergrad.
So I was looking through
my old notes, basically.
There was a lot
of stuff in here.
And I ended up taking out maybe
2/3 of it for the final script.
But this is what got me started.
Mucus as a problem.
Mucus as a solution to things.
Just like random, cool
facts about mucus.
The research that's happening.
And just the process of going
through all of these things
helped me discover a story.
And just the process did.
So if you would find it helpful
to do sort of a brain dump idea
in the next 10 minutes,
feel free to do that.
Again, we're not
saying that you have
to do any of these methods.
But this is what's
helped me personally
in the practice of doing this.
So feel free to do
something like this.
I had some ideas of
demos I could do.
Ted Ed.
When they recruit
people to write scripts,
they have a requirement
that you have
a sharable fact in your video.
So what's the fact in the
video that's going to go viral?
So I was brainstorming, what
could be some shareable facts
in the script?
And then I was thinking
about what's the point?
Mucus is alive.
that actually ended up not
making the final video at all.
But the exercise and
the act of doing that
helped me figure out what
the point of the video
was going to be.
PROFESSOR: So let's maybe
spend like 5 to 10 minutes
of just quiet time for you to
really think about your topic.
And then maybe we can like
slowly check in with people,
and then maybe
come back together
and see if people are
struggling with anything.
I assume that from
you're head nods that
sounds like a good plan?
Yes.
OK.
[NO SPEECH]
PROFESSOR: Do you
know of omnivores?
What is it?
Not omnivores.
What's it called?
Opportunivores.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
They're people who
like running food.
It's like a--
AUDIENCE: They discover?
PROFESSOR: So I have
this great story
I'll have to give you if this
is what you decide to do.
A non-fiction piece
that was written
by a journalist exploring
people who actually live off
of people's decomposing
food scraps.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so like freegans?
PROFESSOR: I guess.
Is that another work for it?
Like I know-- I actually
do know some people
who their diets is basically
composed of free food.
PROFESSOR: Right?
And like what is fermenting?
Fermenting if like
beer and cheese.
And like fermenting is a whole
other concept in here, right?
Which is actually a
really cool concept.
I know.
I kind of was like there's a lot
of things like beer and cheese.
And I was like, what
isn't there anything
of that I'm interested in?
I guess the conflict I
have right now is that is
seems people are more
interested in volcanoes.
And that's easier because I
actually know a lot about this.
This would be something I'd
have to learn about a lot.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: But that's kind
of what I want to do more.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Is I want to learn
a topic as opposed to just
going in with what I know.
PROFESSOR: What makes you
excited about this topic?
AUDIENCE: I don't know
anything about it.
And I think that's something
that happens a lot.
Whether it's because
my dorm hall's
terrible at
maintaining our fridge.
And there's always
things in there.
PROFESSOR: That's rotting?
AUDIENCE: That's rotting.
And I'm looking at
it, and it's like wow.
This is the-- how did
this beautiful broccoli
turn into this black muck?
And different things like that.
That's actually something
that fascinates me a lot.
Like the transformation.
PROFESSOR: And like
why do things--
AUDIENCE: And like
different things.
Why things-- some things
decompose in different ways
like where if meats starts to
rot, then even if you cook it,
it's not going--
that's not good.
You just can't eat it.
But some things you can kind of
like say, well, if you cook it
well enough, it'll be fine.
And also like the whole concept
of how you prevent this.
you know like these--
I was looking at it
and there's like all
these different ways
that you could prevent--
just like they have the three
topics of like killing things.
How to like bacteria
and fungi that cause it.
And it's like attacking
like preventing
like their functions.
I think they're
like their enzymes.
And then there's more
like controlling a growth.
PROFESSOR: So maybe-- I
mean I love this story
that you picked.
PS remind me sometime to
tell you about the story
I wrote for Backpacker
magazine where
I took a whole
backpacks worth of food
and saw what rotted over
the course of a week
to see what the best
foods are to take hiking.
So I did a piece on
this in my earlier days
and it was really fun.
But I actually found
that there were
maggots that showed up in the
completely sealed bologna.
And it grossed me out entirely.
Because you like, they must
have been there from the start.
That's terrifying.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's-- Yeah.
The things that like
start and they--
with meat and like things
that the animal has--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Go through the entire
process and they survive.
PROFESSOR: Right.
But the story that
I love that you just
told me about was you
going into your dorm
and seeing that broccoli
and being like, why did this
happen?
And what does it smell so bad?
And you can make your whole
five minute piece about that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Do you
know what I mean?
Like just that little anecdote
of you looking in your fridge
and seeing this nasty
broccoli and being
like, why does this happen?
That's your story.
You know?
AUDIENCE: And I thought--
PROFESSOR: And then all
this comes from that.
AUDIENCE: It's just
like a very big topic.
Because I made my
video and I looked
and I don't really go
that far into anything.
And it's five minutes already.
You know?
And I've--
PROFESSOR: But if you were
to really narrowly look
at what's going on
what that broccoli,
that's actually a really
great five minute piece.
AUDIENCE: Because like, I
mean, I looked on YouTube.
They have this time-lapse
of things decaying.
But there's nothing ever
explains why, or how,
or what does it.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Like,
basically the only thing
that there is on the
internet in like video form
is watching things.
But there's no explanation.
PROFESSOR: Of like why does
it become so darn smelly?
Right?
AUDIENCE: You know, I can
go and read academic papers.
But academic papers
are academic papers.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But also the question-- I
mean, if you think about this,
if your center becomes
instead of food decomposition,
but broccoli.
The broccoli.
Right?
Looking at that broccoli.
So many questions
come out of that.
Like when is it
not OK to eat it?
It looks nasty.
But is it still safe to eat it?
I'm like what's
happening in there?
And how long can I expect
my broccoli to last?
There's this cool
people you might end up
wanting to talk to you.
That I went to an innovation
conference last year
the-- I'll have to
look up the name.
These people made this device to
be able to tell you when you're
food is rotting in your fridge.
And it's an innovation
that's happening
on campus that
you could actually
go talk to those people.
That they've actually
really, really
thought deeply about food waste.
And created a device that
attach to your fridge
to tell you like bananas
are going bad in three days.
You know?
And they are people on campus.
So I have to think
about their name,
but there's this
really cool lab that's
actually really exploring this
topic that you could talk to.
AUDIENCE: And then
I actually just
had a random idea
that was completely
unrelated to everything
I had before.
Which is the concept of a
world without decomposition,
and what that would look like.
PROFESSOR: Why do things die?
Or sort of--
AUDIENCE: A world in which
things did not decompose.
PROFESSOR: What would
that looked like?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Which better
gets to the question,
why do things die?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Right?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
mean things would die
but then they would
just sit there.
PROFESSOR: Right?
Why do things decompose?
AUDIENCE: And if they had
to be broken down by other
means than just
bacteria and fungi.
PROFESSOR: The
decomposition cycle.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Without a need for
carbon and nitrogen cycles.
PROFESSOR: That's much
conceptually harder
than a concrete broccoli.
But you can allude to
this in the exploration
of that broccoli.
Do you know what I mean?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: By looking at one
thing really, really deeply,
you actually allow yourself the
ability to abstract from it.
That-- think for a few
minutes about that broccoli.
A little more.
Cool
How are you doing?
AUDIENCE: After
talking to [INAUDIBLE],
I realized probably
my initial idea
is I want to go into
talking about how
we go from [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Time?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I will think of that.
And then another topic, closely
related topic [INAUDIBLE].
The one I submitted was the
pre-conceptual time traveling.
PROFESSOR: Is time
travel even possible?
Is that the question?
AUDIENCE: No.
Not really.
More along the lines of
problems with time traveling.
Like for example, there's
the grandfather paradox.
And then the idea and theory
of the multiverse universe.
And multiverse
theory [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But I mean,
even like the idea
of like is time travel possible
is a really cool concept.
AUDIENCE: But it's really broad.
Right?
AUDIENCE: That's why I decided
not to delve into time travel,
if it's possible.
Rather looking at
what happened--
why concepts for then.
I think maybe it's--
PROFESSOR: I think
you're still too broad.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: What-- to tell me
more about what you actually
do in your studies.
AUDIENCE: That's
what you think--
PROFESSOR: But
what about-- like,
there's got to be
something in there that's
really exciting to you
that you could explore.
AUDIENCE: I mean, yeah.
But I really doubt
kids would even
really want to see how a
computer does information.
Because mostly I do AI.
So, it's lot-- It's to do
a lot with like filtering
of information and deciding
what we do with our information.
PROFESSOR: But I mean, this
came up with a different group.
Which is when type-- filtering
information's actually
really interesting.
Like when I Google
something, how
does my computer
know what to send me?
That's actually a really
interesting question.
Right?
If I'm using Google
Shopper, how does it know--
AUDIENCE: Identify what you--
PROFESSOR: You know?
And explaining
that like a system.
That's actually interesting.
AUDIENCE: Bringing that layman
terms can be challenging.
PROFESSOR: But important.
Right?
AUDIENCE: That
would be quite hard.
PROFESSOR: I mean, is it
possible to pick something
that you do that's conceptually
hard but to really flesh it
out to challenge yourself
to think about how
to describe that or show that.
Like the train concept.
A little bit hard.
But I kind of got it.
Right?
Is there something that you
could-- something in your work
that you're passionate
about and you
know a lot about that
you think is actually
really useful for the
public to know, as well.
AUDIENCE: That's really
hard to think about.
I honestly don't
think anything's
that relevant to the public.
PROFESSOR: What do you want
to do with your degree?
AUDIENCE: Probably
robotics, itself.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Robots are really cool topics.
So what about--
what about robots?
AUDIENCE: They
contain information.
Probably how they input--
how they take input
and how they decide what to do.
PROFESSOR: Great this
is an awesome topic.
Can you think of one
very specific question
that you could
answer, ask a robot,
and how it would be able to
figure out the answer it?
Yes or no?
Have you ever design a simple
robot or a simple machine?
AUDIENCE: Really rudimentary.
PROFESSOR: Or like is there
any way of very simply showing
how a machine makes a decision?
I'm trying-- you
know what I mean?
What I'm trying
to push you to do
is think about it robotics
were exciting to you,
is there one teeny--
AUDIENCE: The concept behind
them are quite abstract.
That's the thing.
They're really like
mathematically behaving.
That's why I'm thinking of it.
I'm not sure how really
it can be brought across.
Or whether is should be
brought across in that space.
So I was actually exploring
something maybe a bit more.
Maybe more on like a pain.
I was a medic back
in the military.
So dealt with a lot.
Like every day we
see people coming in
and looking for pain killers.
So maybe a bit more like for
people to understand better.
PROFESSOR: Like do I take
and Advil or an aspirin?
Like do I take a--
AUDIENCE: They're
roughly the same thing.
Yeah.
Something like that.
What is the difference in
two kinds of medication?
And why do we take one
more than the other?
But we just assume more
useful than the other.
I don't think so.
It's more like--
it's like doctor, MD.
You know?
OK.
A bit more explanatory
around there.
So I was thinking of
something like that.
PROFESSOR: But I'd hate to use
to not talk about robots when
that's what you're
studying, and that's
what you're passionate about,
just because it's hard.
AUDIENCE: I don't think
it's because its hard.
I mean, if it were to be an
instructional video for someone
at my level, maybe
it's not un-doable.
PROFESSOR: But is there
anything within robots
that you think is a cool idea.
Simple.
A simple, simple,
simple something.
So not everything about
how a robot works.
But even how to get-- just
something very simple.
I don't know your
world old enough
to be able to help you think
about what is that thing.
But I challenge you to
think for a few minutes
really deeply about
what within the robots
is a simple enough concept?
Do you have an idea?
AUDIENCE: I actually--
just listening in
and I know something I
think is really cool.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: I very basic
on-- but this might still
be too complex.
But probability based maps.
AUDIENCE: Probability-based
maps as in based
on the probability of
what-- something happening
that you predict what that is?
AUDIENCE: Like
when the robot has
to construct a map of
an area it doesn't know.
AUDIENCE: Oh, mapping.
Yuck.
Not my favorite project.
Done before.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: But if you
can think-- maybe you
brainstorm for a
second about robots
to see if you can get narrow
enough that it's a concept.
PROFESSOR: I mean, I think
that there's a seedling here.
Right?
But like what is the
relate-ability and the drama
that's hooking people in?
Right?
Because I personally
think that it's
fascinating that we live in
the 21st century with all
these super computers.
Yet this seemingly
basic problem of you
have constraints x, y, z.
You can only work
four hours in the day.
You need to make chairs and
you need to make tables.
What's the optimal number of
chairs and tables to make?
Like, that seems like a question
that we would be able to solve.
And the fact that we
theoretically actually can't is
interesting.
Except there's not enough
at stake in that example.
Right?
Like people will say,
oh, we lose a couple
cents on making chairs.
Like, that's no big deal.
But if you say something like,
because integer programs can't
be solved right
now, this is what's
preventing us from knowing--
like this is the reason, or one
of the reasons why
companies can only
achieve like certain profit
margins, for instance.
What would happen if we
can solve integer programs?
Like what would happen
to humanity, I guess?
You know?
AUDIENCE: Hm.
PROFESSOR: Do you know?
I mean, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: It's just
means that-- when
they say you can't
solve a problem,
just saying that you
can't solve is easier
than the-- you
actually can solve it.
By the way to solve
it is to just go
through every single
point on the graph
PROFESSOR: So it's
very inefficient.
AUDIENCE: It's just complete--
PROFESSOR: So like it limits
us to the types of problems
we can solve.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You can solve it
for like very small variables.
Like in this case,
it's two variables.
So you can solve it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But you can't solve until
you proof the problems.
AUDIENCE: The more
variables than-- actually I
was mentioning this before.
I think it's called
it n problem.
AUDIENCE: What?
You know how you were saying as
long as the number of variables
increased, the number of times
you must try exponentially
that you can't really
solve the problem.
AUDIENCE: There's a
concept called NPI.
Or NP.
So it's about
categorizing a problem.
How difficult a problem is.
And if it's harder
than this problem--
PROFESSOR: I think that's very--
AUDIENCE: Like problem in the
world can be made into a type
of problem called a--
I'm forgetting like--
PROFESSOR: You
should write this.
I think like maybe this
might be specific enough.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
This sounds really-- because--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: You don't have
to baby anything down
for the audience.
You know what I mean?
Like you don't have to talk
to them like they're ten.
AUDIENCE: Because that helps
encourage the conversations
afterward, too.
Because like when I watch
a video about something
that I'm unfamiliar with,
if I want to learn more
I'll go out and search the
words that I don't know.
Like as you with
the sixth graders,
maybe they kept
asking questions.
If they're curious
about something
they'll keep wanting
to know about things.
And so-- and they're
are a lot more intel--
you think sixth grade
was way too long ago.
But they were very like
they're actually intelligent.
They're actually curious.
So you don't want
to take out things
that you're saying
just because you
think it's too
intelligent for them,
or it's too far
above their level.
Because if you
transition well into it,
if you script it properly, and
do the proper build up-- here's
your introduction.
Now these are the details
I'm going to talk about.
Then they'll remember
some of those details,
and look up the things that
they still want to know.
AUDIENCE: Is it OK if we
just use the vocabulary,
but instead of the-- because to
say what a problem can become
two separate [INAUDIBLE].
Like a lot of--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So for tonight's
assignment, we're
going to have you
guys just write
a rough draft of a script.
And at this point,
I think it's OK
if you want to err on the side
of having too much jargon.
That's OK.
Because George and I are going
to workshop all the scripts
with you tomorrow.
And we'll--
It's always a fine balance.
Because you don't want to
sit and define everything.
Right?
Like, it's OK to
challenge your audience.
You don't want to alienate
them by talking in a language
that they don't understand.
Right?
So it's a balance between that.
I think for tonight, we want
you just like get something
on paper.
And so don't get too
stressed about that.
Really focus on what
the overarching story's
going to be.
AUDIENCE: This is
day two of the class
and scripts take like a long
time to write and refine and--
PROFESSOR: So
we're not expecting
perfection or anything.
AUDIENCE: I'm just concerned
about like something like this
because there's no
like visual elements
like what you were saying.
PROFESSOR: So do you want me to
show you the computer-- Or have
you see the computer?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I've seen-- You're
talking about the one
where he puts like
these pin balls.
PROFESSOR: With the balls.
Yeah.
I don't know any videos
on top of my head.
But what you might
want to try doing
is just looking on
YouTube for maybe
like VSauce of
Veritasium videos that
were about computer
engineering and see
what they used visually.
Sometimes it's just their
persona like on screen.
VSauce does that
a lot because he
talks a lot about
psychological concepts
that are sort of
hard to visualize.
And it's just him
on screen talking.
He's just visually
engaging that way.
I do agree.
This is going to be
hard to-- it's going
to be hard to visualize.
But maybe this is a place
where animations could help.
And I always think animation
should be used sparingly.
People have a tendency
to rely on animation
because think it's like
cheaper, or easier to make.
And when Josh come in,
maybe he and I and you
can talk a little bit more about
how you would implement that
exactly.
But having a person with just
an animated overlay like you
saw at the beginning
of that video, that
can be a really simple
solution to a way
to engage people visually.
But I think the idea
is-- personally,
I think the idea is
very fascinating.
The notion that we live in
a world where we think we've
achieved so much
technological prowess.
But a problem that seems so
basic like that understanding
how to solve four,
five, six things
is actually incredibly
challenging.
And this is why.
This is the thing that we can
conceptualize in our minds
as human.
But when you try to get
a computer to do it,
like it's actually impossible.
It's impossible.
I went to this talk
awhile back given
by one of the guys who runs the
Humanoid Robots Group at MIT.
And he was saying
how it's so hard
to program a humanoid
robot, a bi-pedal robot
to walk like a human behaves.
And it's because
we walk every day.
Right?
And we don't think
anything of it.
But to model the
movement of your knee
bending and putting
your foot down,
it's actually possible
to mathematically model
with a precision of reality.
And I don't remember
the exact math about it.
But I remember hearing
this notion that
like there's no way in math
for us to model something
that we do in reality every day.
Right?
So even if we create like the
world's biggest super computer,
a robot is never going come
close to what the human body
can achieve in their sleep.
You know?
And I thought that was
such an interesting concept
that humans are still
like so complex,
even with all the advances
we've made in robotics.
And that was a
theme that we tried
hit in one of our
episodes, actually.
Does that help a little bit?
I don't know.
Maybe you just have
more questions.
So at the end of
the whole treatise,
we each will come with
a video and post it
PROFESSOR: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
It'll be great.
AUDIENCE: Can I just picture--
AUDIENCE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So I mean, I
have one of an algorithm.
And like the
simplest algorithm I
can think of this is one search.
So I was just thinking
like wal-- You know, wal--
or whatever you call it.
Where is Waldo?
PROFESSOR: Oh, Where is Waldo?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So like just-- it would
probably be like just some guy
just hiding in the building.
And then he'll be like, what's
the best way to find Waldo?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Then we'll just
be running around.
Row
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
like-- so first wave,
open every door
in the university
and you just keep
going that way.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Then there's another
way where you keep going up.
Yeah but then I start to
realize that the energy might
break down somewhere half way.
Because the algorithm
on the [INAUDIBLE]
was a binary search which
is just like, you cut half.
And then you see whether,
is Waldo on the right side
or the left side?
And then you cut half again.
And less, and less.
PROFESSOR: I think
that's very interesting.
What is the final application
of search algorithms?
AUDIENCE: Google.
PROFESSOR: Like Google?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think as long as you relate
it back to the big picture
of like why that's
such an awesome thing.
Because what you
don't want happening
is people to think
like, OK, cool.
I get that.
It's a binary search.
He split things
in half and half.
So what?
Like why should I care?
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: You should
care because it's
like what drives the most
used website in the world.
And I think relating
it back to that--
like that's what we tried to
do with the switches video.
Is like, OK I get
that the billiard ball
hit with the switch on or off.
But we tied it back
at the very end
to say like this
toy has 20 switches
but most computer have
like billions of switches.
And that's what makes
a semi-conductor.
And that's what makes every
modern electronic possible.
As long as you relate back to
the big picture, to the thing
that people relate to, the
thing that people use every day.
I think that can be powerful.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: I mean, I also-- I
like this path in GPS thing.
Like how exactly
does a GPS work?
How do you find your way?
You know?
Knowing what-- knowing
your location in GPS?
I know but I was-- like
mapping a path, that's
a different problem.
PROFESSOR: OK
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GPS--
PROFESSOR: It's like how
does Google Maps know?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I
see what you mean.
PROFESSOR: We are
about out of time.
Maybe we should get
everyone back together.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
Thank you, Danny.
PROFESSOR: I don't
have too much to say.
Except for just the
daily assignment.
So another daily blog.
Thank you all for posting your
stuff on Tumblr yesterday.
Keep in mind that you don't have
to do a text post like I did.
I just did that as an example.
But if you guys want
to do a video blog.
If you want to just vlog
on your laptop webcam,
that's totally fine.
But if you end up
taking pictures
of any of the lectures,
or taking videos
during the lecture, you're
free to post those, too.
And just post them
with a hashtag day
two and your Kerberos ID.
All the stuff that is on Tumblr.
I'd also do the day two thing.
And then a quick 200
or 300 rough script
based on some of the
stuff we talked about now.
Don't worry about being
too jargony in this.
This is really about pulling
the overarching story.
We're going to work out
the details of what's
the best wording to use.
We're going to work out
some of the minutiae a bit
tomorrow during our
scripting workshop.
For tonight, think about
what's the point of the video,
and what the overarching
story of the video is.
Those are really
the things I want
you to think about tonight.
If you get so
stuck, and you just
can't think of
something to write,
write down some facts like
I was showing earlier.
Just come to class
with something
that we can work with tomorrow.
Because tomorrow's going to
be a really informal day.
[INAUDIBLE] and I are
just going to workshop
and then table read some of
this stuff that we've written.
And figure out how to implement
the theoretical things
that we were talking
about in the last two
days in a more practical sense.
So does anyone
have any questions
about those assignments?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you also bring
back the canvas tomorrow?
PROFESSOR: No.
Tomorrow will just workshopping.
You will need them back
at least on Friday.
I'll send you guys an
email the night before
and the day we meet
in the final class.
PROFESSOR: When I-- just as
something to think about.
When I walked around and led to
some of you guys more deeply,
I feel like a lot
of you are sort
of struggling with this
same concept of broad
versus detailed.
And my two cents on it is that
by asking a broad question
but going very narrowly
in with one example,
you actually end up being
able to bring people back
up to that broader framework.
So if you pick
something-- like we
talked about food composition.
And we started
exploring further.
Maybe talking about why
a piece of broccoli rots.
And when is it too rotten for
me to eat that I get sick?
Is actually the
perfect focus for him
to ask all these other questions
about food composition.
And that by focusing really
narrowly on that broccoli,
we actually get to ask
a lot more questions.
Right?
Like with shipbuilding.
Why does something
really sink or float?
But that question
diving really narrowly
into one scenario
of one ship sinking.
And why does it do this?
It allows us to be able to
ask some broader questions.
Why-- the braces.
The opposite.
Right?
I want to talk about braces
and what they do to your teeth.
But all right, let's
think about if that's
a specific example, what's
the question that we're
trying to think through?
And I feel all into a
kind of in that place
right now where you're trying
to figure out what specific
story do I tell in order to get
these bigger, bigger concepts?
The narrower you are
in that microcosm,
the easier it is
to extrapolate out.
Because it lets you really
dive deeply into that topic.
So if you have a really,
really broad topic still,
see if you can get
it really narrow.
And then from that it allows
you to get broad again.
If that makes sense.
PROFESSOR: And that's
why I personally
like going with the
whole just trying
to list out as many facts as
I can with this snot thing.
Because it was just sort
of, snot is awesome.
OK.
Like, you know,
why is it awesome?
What does that even mean?
And so I'm listing out
all these specific things
that people study about it.
And that helped me delve
into the tangible examples
that I gave.
That allowed me, at
the end, to go back
out to the story of
this material that
protects you every day,
and is amazing and awesome.
PROFESSOR: And I know we're
just about-- we're actually
over time, so I apologize.
But I realize that
some of you may not
know how to implement
Elizabeth's task of asking you
to actually write your script.
And that may be an
overwhelming task.
Is that feeling
like that right now?
Like sitting down and actually
putting something on paper,
you don't know where to start?
Or do you feel like you know to
at least dump something down?
Sort of like you know,
Paul, colon, says this.
Picture of something in here.
Like just jot it down.
Don't worry about format.
Don't worry about any of that.
PROFESSOR: We're going to go
over all the details tomorrow.
We just need an idea.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Just dump-- so when
she says script,
that word may be
intimidating right now,
because a script can
look certain ways
in different genres.
Like a film script looks
very different from a theater
script, versus this
kind of transcript.
Don't worry about anything
other than getting
some ideas on paper.
And we'll deal with all
of the other stuff later.
If that makes sense.
PROFESSOR: And I'll
stick around afterwards,
if anyone wants to
talk specifically.
Yeah?
And just upload all
that stuff to Tumblr.
PROFESSOR: And we're
both available.
And we're all
available via email.
So if any of you are
struggling tonight,
and you need bounce an
idea off of one of us,
don't hesitate to do that.
I do not check email
usually until after 8:00 PM
when my son goes to bed.
But I will respond.
So if you have a
question or anything,
don't hesitate to
bounce ideas off.
And I do really get back to you
guys, as does-- do all of us.
So that's all for today.
You guys can pack up and leave.
But really just get ideas
down more than anything.
We will help you with
everything else tomorrow.
PROFESSOR: Even if drawing
is the way that helps you.
Just get something down.
PROFESSOR: But do
get words down.
We need to have like some words.
That would be great.
AUDIENCE: Is the script
supposed to go on a tablet, or?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Good work, guys.
PROFESSOR: All right.